vive les vacances et en octobre rendez
vous à l'espace régler au coin des
enfants pour s'occuper créé dessinée et
sans chanter des ateliers créatifs sur
le thème de l'identité sont proposés le
mercredi 12 octobre de 14h à 16h dessins
et collages sur le thème des portraits
créole pour les enfants à partir de 7
ans le samedi 15 octobre 20h toujours en
dessins et coloriages qui suis-je pour
cette fois ci il est plus petit des
quatre ans retour dans le temps en temps
au coin du feu avec grand mère kal
keller il est le samedi 29 octobre pour
les 4 ans et plus deux événements de
poids pour ses vacances à l'espace
régler pour commencer l'atelier d'art
actuel avec chloé robert l'habit fait le
moine au ces le stage d'arts plastiques
et photographique autour des identités
de la créolité
plusieurs dates pour cet atelier le
mardi 18 le mercredi 19 le jeudi 20 et
le vendredi 21 de 14 heures à 17 heures
pour les 7 ans et plus autre événement
l'atelier lire et dessiner avec rocky le
héros de la collection jeunesse de
l'auteur stéphane valentin de passage à
la réunion pour le salon du livre et de
la jeunesse
comment créer une bande dessinée c'est
quoi une maison d'édition d'où viennent
les idées
autant de questions qui trouveront leurs
réponses dans l'atelier de steffon
valentin ça se passe le mercredi 26
octobre de 14h à 15h30 un atelier ouvert
pour les 7 ans et plus les comptes c'est
bon pour les bébés avec à l'honneur les
animaux de la réunion et les fruits de
la réunion avec marlène mussard rendez
vous le mercredi 12 et le vendredi 15
octobre pour les 4 ans et plus qui
devront être accompagnés d'un adulte
le coin des enfants continuent les
ateliers habituels avec tous les
mercredis et vendredis de 9 heures à 11
heures pour un moment de découverte
livre à partir de 4 ans pour participer
à ces ateliers en seul numéro le 06 92
97 40 26 du côté de st le hamas car un
jardin botanique au tarif d'entrée du
musée des visites guidées et chasse au
trésor autour des légumineuses également
découvrir le green cause une exposition
de dominique laporte pour partir à la
découverte de la biodiversité dans la
vie de l'homme
mascarin qui propose également une
animation autour des légumineuses nous
grimpons demain en travail proposées à
l'occasion de l'année internationale des
légumineuses
à voir aussi au ropa joyau naturel des
éparses une découverte scientifique des
îles éparses comme par exemple juan de
nova tromelin ou encore europa qui font
partie des terres australes et
antarctiques françaises
pour tout renseignement un seul numéro
le 02 62 24 92 27 saint leu où une halte
est aussi possible au musée du sel pour
découvrir une exposition originale salle
des los andes qui présente le travail de
soigner hors du commun d'un champignon
bolivie au pérou
les photos qui propose de découvrir les
pratiques l'unique d'exploitation du sel
à plus de 3000 mètres d'altitude dans la
cordillière des andes
tous les musées départementaux vous
invite à découvrir ou à redécouvrir leur
exposition
rendez vous sur le www.cegedim.fr ou sur
le www.servigardes.fr slash culture
bonnes vacances à tous